saludos en esta ocasión vamos a hablar
de las diferentes funciones del dinero
el dinero es algo que todos usamos día
con día y tenemos cierta idea de cómo
funciona y para qué sirve pero siempre
es interesante dar un paso atrás y
contemplar qué es el dinero qué es lo
que le da el valor y por qué la historia
se usaron ciertas cosas como dinero y
otras no no sólo se ha usado el oro y la
plata como dinero sino también otras
cosas como sal o cigarros pero hay
ciertas cosas que no se usan como dinero
y los economistas por lo general dividen
las funciones del dinero en tres
categorías diferentes aunque a veces las
personas agregan una cuarta función pero
no vamos a hablar sobre esta en este
vídeo aquí veremos las tres funciones
principales del dinero que es lo que
hace por nosotros imaginemos que somos
economistas y que estamos filosofando
sobre el dinero y cuáles son sus
funciones podríamos comenzar pensando
cómo sería el mundo sin dinero por
ejemplo imaginaros que somos abogados
proporcionamos consejo legal a las
este es el servicio que proporcionamos y
es la forma en que nosotros agregamos
valor a la economía digamos que estamos
remodelando nuestra oficina y
necesitamos una silla así que queremos
salir y comprar una silla y lo que
necesitamos es encontrar una persona que
fabrique sillas aquí tenemos a esta
persona cuya forma de agregar valor a la
economía es produciendo sillas las hace
bonitas y de buena calidad el problema
aquí es que como no existe el dinero
tenemos que hacer un trueque con esta
persona a esto se le llama economía de
trueque y para hacerlo ya que nosotros
nos especializamos en leyes pues
tendremos que esperar que esa persona
que hace sillas necesite de algún
consejo legal para que podamos hacer un
trueque de nuestros servicios por una de
sus sillas esperamos que esta persona
necesite de los servicios que nosotros
estamos proporcionando que en este caso
son servicio
legales y si este es el caso tenemos la
buena fortuna de que podemos
proporcionar servicios legales para
conseguir la silla que necesitamos pues
todo estará muy bien pero esto sería
bastante raro debido a que nuestra
profesión es bastante especializada y
esta idea en la que nosotros necesitamos
algo y esta persona necesita algo que
podemos satisfacer mutuamente de hecho
tiene un nombre y se llama la doble
coincidencia de necesidades y vale la
pena escribirlo ya que muchas veces las
personas se refieren a esto cuando
hablan de la economía de trueque y con
economía de trueque me refiero a este
tipo de dinámicas pero escaladas al
nivel de la sociedad en donde todos
realizan trueques con base en su
especialidad o en lo que hacen y en lo
que necesitan los demás y claro que en
un mundo de dinero esto luce absurdo
porque en la realidad lo que hacemos es
que nosotros como abogados
proporcionamos servicios legales
y los proporcionamos a cualquier persona
que los necesite y no basándonos en lo
que estas personas producen y a cambio
de esto estas personas nos dan dinero
nos dan efectivo nos dan algo que a su
vez nosotros podemos usar y que todas
las personas van a aceptar para adquirir
lo que sea que necesitemos en este caso
sí necesitamos sillas pues vamos con la
persona que produce las sillas para
comprarle algunas le damos dinero y nos
va a dar las sillas y hasta este momento
el dinero sirve a esta función algo
universal a intercambiar y que llamamos
medio de intercambio lo que significa
que cada vez que queramos intercambiar
algo u obtener algo este será el objeto
de valor común que vamos a usar para
intercambiar con el mundo pero esto no
es todo lo que hace el dinero es una
gran parte de lo que hace y permite que
exista en nuestra economía como la
conocemos y nos permite especializarnos
en cosas como servicios legales pero qué
otras cosas hace el dinero sin el cual
sería difícil hacer en un mundo sin
dinero digamos que como abogados damos
servicios legales y proporcionamos más
valor del que necesitamos consumir con
la esperanza de ahorrar algo de este
valor quizá más adelante querramos
comprar una casa o pagar la educación de
nuestros hijos por lo que queremos
almacenar valor y ahorrar lo pero en
esta economía de trueque tendríamos que
encontrar algo ya que el dinero no
existe que sea de valor y que pueda yo
almacenar y que no pierda el valor quizá
las sillas no pierdan su valor por lo
que nos convenga a almacenar muchas
sillas o quizá tengamos que comprar
terreno o algo que no pierdas
pero no tendremos un medio de facto con
el que poder hacer esto así que en este
sentido y es algo que normalmente
hacemos con el dinero su segunda función
es el depósito de valor
esto se considera un segundo uso del
dinero que es diferente del medio de
intercambio ya que la idea de tener algo
para intercambiar es diferente a querer
ahorrar valor y para la tercera función
regresemos a este caso en el que
queremos o esperamos intercambiar
servicios legales por sillas una vez que
comenzamos a entrar con detalles
específicos comenzamos a preguntarnos
cuántas horas de servicio legal
corresponden a una silla y si queremos
comprar algo diferente por ejemplo si
vamos a comprar nuestra despensa cuántas
horas de servicio legal son necesarias
para adquirir una manzana y de forma
similar la persona que fabrica las
sillas tiene que ir y preguntarse cada
vez que quiera comprar una manzana
cuántas sillas corresponden a una
manzana y tratar de relacionar valores
como estos puede volverse bastante
complicado por lo que necesitamos algo
para medir el valor de todo lo demás
en la economía a todos le damos el valor
de la moneda local ya sean pesos ya sean
euros ya sean dólares dependiendo de en
donde nos encontramos así que las
personas dicen que el dinero cumple la
función de unidad de cuenta
lo que básicamente significa que nos da
un número base nos da el significado del
valor 1 si esto vale 5 pesos entonces
qué es lo que valdrá 10 pesos quizá una
hora del trabajo legal equivalga a mil
pesos y quizá una de estas sillas valga
300 pesos y de esta manera podemos
comparar los valores de diversos objetos
o servicios lo que hace que esta función
sea muy interesante ya que es algo que
fácilmente dejamos de apreciar hasta que
nos damos cuenta de lo importante que es
tener algo así en el siguiente vídeo
hablaremos sobre un caso histórico de la
hiperinflación en brasil en donde
básicamente lo que ocurrió fue que el
dinero perdió algunas de estas funciones
y podemos ver qué es lo que le ocurre a
la sociedad cuando lo que se supone que
es el dinero deja de servir a sus
funciones y con esto terminamos este
vídeo nos vemos en el siguiente